at a virtual court hearing for alleged  u.s capitol writer anthony antonio  his lawyer argued that he committed  those acts because  of fox itis or fox mania because the guy  lost his job and believed everything  that he was  watching on fox news and that's why he  committed the prime of writing in answer  to your questions no fox news is not  going to face any repercussions as a  result of this even if these allocations  are true  because remember people are responsible  for their own actions love or hate fox  news they don't make people  do anything i would love to tell you  more about this court hearing but it was  interrupted by  fellow alleged u.s capitol writer landon  copeland who  heard these words was incensed and just  went on a complete  rage interrupted everything so in the  future we're going to be seeing a lot of  these guys  in court